- For him, the key decision on Vietnam
would have come in his
second and final term
when he can no longer run for reelection.
Matters enormously.
And then I would say that
I think he and his brother
saw this a little differently,
even in '62 and '63.
I think Bobby...
Bobby was more hawkish.
I think in the missile crisis,
Jack was really the only one
in the room on the EXCOMM
who was totally committed to
seeking a political solution
to the missile crisis question.
But even on Indochina,
it seems to me that there is
some daylight between the two brothers.
Now, last thing I'll say is, of course,
that a surviving JFK,
it would have been...
I'm not wanting to say here
that it would have been easy for him,
especially in domestic political terms,
to withdraw from the war.
But I think he ultimately would have
if the alternative is massive escalation.